foreign
[Music]
s have been in the POI world forever
longer than I have in fact and it seems
like everybody seems to think that they
look really cool so why do so few people
actually do them Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm going
to try to answer the question that it
seems like absolutely nobody other than
me is trying to ask right now why aren't
anti-brids more popular but before we
dive in I do just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
Ultra POI for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca beckonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
so it appears that DC is starting to
very gingerly warm up for the spring
we've been experiencing a bunch of cold
snaps throughout February and the
beginning of March and now it appears as
though the trajectory of temperatures is
actually going up which is great because
uh I have been cooped up inside way too
much lately and I'm glad to get outside
but all that's neither here nor there
we're here to talk about anti-brids and
anti-brids have a long-storied history
in the POI World they definitely predate
me the first time I became aware of them
was actually in the Arizona transmission
video that alien John and Zan Moore
uploaded way back in I want to say it
was 2009 among the many tricks they
demoed and that included anti-brids such
as isolation versus cat eye as well as
triquetra versus static spin later on I
got exposed to the work of Ronald
McLaughlin new to immemora and Ivan Mel
gorbanov all of whom made anti-brids an
interesting and intriguing part of their
flow and I was utterly captivated by by
them I made it a point to add them into
my flow and use them whenever I could so
much so that people began to identify
this particular type of trick with my
style which came as news to me because
as far as I was concerned I was just
ripping it off from the artist who'd
inspired me but hey zandon invent Zan's
Diamond either so I guess that's just
how it goes sometimes but then I started
to notice something kind of weird like
every time I posted a video that heavily
featured the use of anti-brids or
anti-brid transitions I would get a
mountain of positive feedback and yet I
never saw most other people doing them
at all there would always be a small
handful of people of course but
strangely enough for as much as people
seem to like them very few people were
doing them so why on Earth would this be
why would there be a kind of poi trick
that people seem to universally love and
has been around for more than a decade
and a half and Counting and still it
winds up being practiced by a very small
number of people so I have some thoughts
on this so I'm going to share them with
you in this video I think that there are
five major reasons why anti-brids never
took off and became more popular
and I think there are some reasons why
we should change this so reason number
one and this is really stupid and kind
of shallow but anti-brids just have such
an odd name it's really a portmanteau of
two other words that is anti-spin which
is incredibly specific to POI and
hybrids and somehow we wound up with
this Frankenstein of a term that most
people don't understand let alone being
able to use it properly to describe a
great variety of different tricks and it
doesn't help that a lot of people
misspell it as anti-bird or just
otherwise are unclear on what the
concept means to begin with
so it's one of these cases where we have
a bit of jargon that then becomes kind
of a unintentional gatekeeper keeping
people from actually getting to enjoy
the thing reason number two and
admittedly this is connected so much for
reason number one is that it's not the
easiest concept to get your head around
like think about it the vast majority of
poi tricks and concepts by and large
involve the hands performing similar
operations or at least performing in the
same hand path anti-brids require us to
throw this concept out the window and
you know even a lot of say vtg hybrids
still happen with the hands both tracing
out the same Circle things get in order
of magnitude more difficult when we have
to train our hands to be doing
completely different things at the same
time and it's not like the name makes
the concept self-evident it's not like
flowers where it's like oh hey it has
petals I get it this is one of those
Concepts where not only do you first
have to under understand what flower is
you also have to understand what a
hybrid is you have to understand what
anti-spin is and you have to understand
that there is a particular hand path
that can be traced out that the POI can
then follow it actually is a multi-step
process and I think that gets in the way
of people learning it and let's be real
here they're quite challenging POI
tricks to do trying to create that sense
of connection between one hand and the
opposite POI head is something that I
don't think we're wired by default to be
able to do I don't think it's something
that we're wired to do even if we have a
good background in POI it takes a whole
extra set of training in order to get
there and that becomes particularly true
some of the more exotic anti-brids for
example one of my first claims to fame
as a tech spinner was learning how to do
isolation versus horizontal cat eye
which at the time I was learning that
trick there were less than a dozen
people in the world that could do it now
a decade and a half on it's still only a
small handful of people that I've seen
be able to demonstrate this trick you
would think that this become one of
those things that would become more
normalized over time but instead it's
remained really exotic not just because
the techniques are difficult but because
the core tricks that it's made out of
are also really difficult and let's also
be honest about this anti-brids and
traditional POI spinning are not a
really great match for each other
finding ways to go back and forth
between the hands sharing a particular
circular path versus having one hand
offset from The Other Well it requires
some pretty awkward transitions to get
there if if I'm going to be honest with
you I have spent years and years and
years trying to find transitions to go
back and forth between these two hand
alignments and even then I feel like I
come up a little short very frequently
and finally even if you get to a point
where you learn the concept behind the
anti-brid you learn the basic techniques
and you learn how to get into it from
traditional POI spinning alignments
well transitioning between anti-brids
then becomes its own entire challenge in
itself and if there's any reason I can
think of off the top of my hand why
anti-brids became associated with my
particular style it would be this I went
really really hard on trying to find
transitions between anti-brids and to
this day whenever I post videos that
feature those kinds of transitions
they're some of the most popular content
that I post okay so this is the story
about why anti-brids are not more
popular so
now let's talk about why they should be
so to start off with I know I've been
repeating this a lot in this video and
I'm going to repeat it one more time
anti-brids look cool everybody agrees on
this point of course there should be
more of them out there but also I tend
to think that if you strip away the
weird name anti-brids are not actually
as difficult as a lot of people think
like some of the basic ones including
cap versus pendulum or static spin
versus extension are things that a lot
of people accidentally come to on their
own it's just a question of connecting
the dots and realizing that they can fit
together with a bunch of other patterns
too and once you've gotten into the
Mercedes and other polyrhythm hybrids it
really is not that big a leap to go to
static spin versus triquetra instead of
extension versus Tri Catra literally the
only difference there is where one of
your hands is sitting I would honestly
argue that the static spin versus
triquetra is probably a little bit less
challenging than extension versus try
Catra because you don't have to worry
about the planes of the two POI
intermeshing and it's got to be said
there are much better resources for
learning about anti-brids than there
when I first started out some of which
I've created but not all of them and I
highly recommend checking them out so
there you go that's my case for why more
people don't do anti-brids and why they
should what do you all out there think
are there reasons not to do anti-brids
or why they're comparatively rare that I
didn't talk about in this video are
there reasons why we should be picking
them up leave me a comment and let me
know if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find it as well as to help my channel
grow
foreign
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching have enjoyed this video and
would like to support the channel here
are three ways that you can do that
number one I have a patreon you can go
sign up for it over at patreon.com
drexfactor POI there's a host of awesome
rewards up on there and you'll be
helping me out in my mission number two
I teach live streaming classes you can
go sign up for whichever session is
going on currently over at crowdcast.io
drexfactor POI it's got a heavy emphasis
on dance so if that's up your alley it's
a good fit finally I have a ton of poi
courses available out on mylearning site
at learn.drexfactor.com they will help
you learn the basics of poi step by step
and take you all the way through
intermediate stuff too so go check all
those things out please and thank you
and if you'd like to check out some of
the other videos I've done on anti-brids
I will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of such videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace